yeah it's a bit of a slow motion
lockdown they announced these temporary
measures for the holiday that just
happened a four week four day holiday as
you say closing restaurants so it's
takeaway only schools and gyms closed
and that was certainly supposed to be
for the holidays supposed to be
temporary measures some suspected they
weren't and that is indeed the case they
will continue indefinitely they've also
added new restrictions a lot of tube
stations and bus lines have been told to
shut that's to try and limit movement in
the city as they try and get on top of
this outbreak the other thing that's
been happening as you can see behind me
is this Mass testing 20 million people
have been told to take three tests last
week the residents of CHA Yang where I
am right now three and a half million
people taking three deaths three tests
sorry on three consecutive days so they
could try and map this outbreak and
understand what's happening and try and
avoid that full lockdown now right now
cases have been pretty uh steady around
50 a day it's not going up but it's not
going down either so that suggests those
temporary measures are going to remain
uh in place for a long time longer but
what they're trying to avoid of course
is the full lockdown of Shanghai the
desperate scenes we saw there of people
running very low on food people
protesting against being locked inside
their flats for coming up to six weeks
the good news about Shanghai is that
cases have fallen from a peak of around
25 000 a day now around 5 000 there is
perhaps hope that people will get out of
that very severe lockdown State media
saying that two-thirds of people now can
leave their homes that doesn't seem to
be case on the ground speaking to people
there their residential compounds who
have a lot of power to tell people what
to do and what not to still keeping
people in their compounds because they
don't want to be in trouble if there is
a flare-up of covid-19 but it does feel
like there is an end to lockdown in
Shanghai inside Beijing here it very
much still hangs in the balance
certainly does okay time for now thank
you